in realtà dapprima perché le scuole
media avevano
delle caramelle durante la ricreazione
ho fondato 18 società in 21 anni e
dovete sapere che mi chiamano sempre
quando bisogna parlare di fallimenti
io quando vedo un numero sconosciuto sul
telefono o e fastweb o uno che vuole che
vada parlargli di fallimenti tenete
presente che di questi diciotto società
ne ho viste fallire ben 14 e sono
orgoglioso di dirlo
tra le società che magari conoscete c'è
sicuramente everly che una volta si
chiamava supermercato 24 prezzi pazzi
fresco frigo e tante altre vi devo dire
la verità io non sono uno da te dx è
infatti la mia presentazione
probabilmente la più brutta che vedrete
oggi ma c'è un motivo per cui sono qui è
un giorno mi arriva una chiamata pensavo
fosse fastweb invece erano gli
organizzatori che mi invitavano come
speaker a questo the licks avevo già la
risposta pronta
no grazie e invece mi hanno detto una
cosa viene a parlarci del tempo delle
start up e ho pensato che fosse un
titolo bellissimo perché il tempo
soprattutto nell'ultimo anno ha assunto
almeno per me molto più valore del tempo
prekop ed in modo particolare parlando
dai talk mi hanno chiesto di venire sul
palco e convincervi che è il momento
giusto per aprire una start up che per
me è come venire qui e vincere a mani
basse
ora ditemi chi tra di voi non vorrebbe
venire a lavorare in una startup alzate
la mano
ecco i classici 23 casi umani e se c è
collegata la prorettrice ne tenga conto
quando ci saranno a fare le valutazioni
finali
comunque al di là dei casi clinici dei
vostri colleghi vi ho portato qualche
slide per farvi vedere esattamente
perché domani mattina lascerete
l'università e andrete a lavorare in una
start up
allora vediamo la prima slide questo è
il prototipo di studenti della cattolica
appena finito l'università va a lavorare
in consulenza nei top della consulenza
ovviamente vedete come si diverte cir
agirà mette in piedi in testa il suo
vicino di scrivania
ovviamente bisogna primeggiare ma
risultato è sempre quello
corre corre corre ma rimane sempre lì
non si sposta di un centimetro
ora ne vediamo un altro ok anche questo
studente della cattolica va in un'altra
grande società
un'altra grande corporation e poi
guardate cosa fa gira gira gira gira ma
anche qui non si sposta mai di un
centimetro
vediamo ecco questo è l'ultimo questo è
l'ultimo esemplare di studente della
cattolica anche lui stesso a società di
consulenza gira gira gira ma anche lui
non si muove mai di un centimetro
ecco questa è probabilmente la vita che
vi aspetterà sembrata in una se andrete
in una big corporation ora finite le
slide ci ho messo tre minuti di volo 15
dire anche ho quasi finito
vorrei che di avere un'altra volta chi è
che non vorrebbe venire a lavorare in
una start up
ok dai non sono più tre sono due i
ragazzi quindi 33 per cento in meno in
tre minuti direi che ha portato a casa
il risultato anche stavolta ma visto che
ce ne sono due che ancora non vogliono
venire
guardiamo un po le tabelline e vediamo i
numeri sapete i numeri non mentono mai
allora vi ho messo un po di ed i numeri
facciamo il caso che vai a lavorare in
una big corporation ai 25 anni e come
primo lavoro ti danno due mila euro
netti al mese
ovviamente lavori dalle 7 del mattino
alle 23 di sera e quando esce
dall'ufficio veneto loculo ti metti a
letto e alle 7 del giorno dopo 6
nuovamente sulla scrivania e questo
ovviamente anche il sabato la domenica
capite ora la storia dei creditori prima
eco ovviamente con 2 mila euro al mese a
milano ti tocca ancora vivere in uno
studentato o in una casa con altri otto
ok però prendi 24k netti all'anno
ok improvvisamente queste grosse
corporation diventano diciamo umane e
decidono di darti 100 euro in più al
mese per ogni anno quindi a 26 anni
prendi 200 ea 35 anni ne prendi 3 mila
netti
ok sapete benissimo che le retribuzioni
non sono queste insomma questa è pura
fantasia non vi pagheranno mai così
tanto
vediamo cosa succede invece si adatta in
una start up eccoli qua i due ovviamente
in fondo alla sala dicono già e visto
che avevamo ragione che prendi meno ed
effettivamente è vero i primi anni
fraine meno the start up son più povere
delle corporation quindi non ti diamo
2.000 euro
ma te ne diamo semplicemente il 1700 ok
però ogni anno ovviamente la startup
cresce te ne diamo 200 in più
tenete presente che nelle mie società si
cresce molto velocemente io ricordo
sempre il primo giorno di solito siamo
in tre persone il primo anno
in quindici secondo anno in 30 in 60 in
120 e così via
ok questo per farvi capire che le start
up crescono che siano sempre maggiori
responsabilità molto velocemente quindi
riprendiamo il discorso della startup il
primo anno prendi 1700 ma quando avrai
35 anni ne prenderà i 3.500 euro netti
al mese quindi di più rispetto a quello
che prenderebbe corpo e qui potrebbe
qualcuno dire sì al riccò
ma c'è un rischio è stata falliscono lo
so benissimo che falliscono in realtà
dovete sapere che ci sono delle domande
da fare durante i colloqui che vanno a
ridurre il vostro rischio ma questo
magari lo spiego ai tedeschi del 2022
ok ora però vi faccio vi dico una cosa
in pochissimi la sanno quindi cercate di
non dirlo in giro
ok soprattutto quelli che hanno già
mandato il curriculum le b corpo di
prima e troveranno questa cosa
incredibile
nelle startup noi regaliamo le quote
della società ai dipendenti vi faccio
però prima vedere una cosa quelle che
sono le valutazioni allora questo è uno
schema di una valutazione di una delle
mie società
ok al giorno uno con in the in mano sono
andato dagli investitori e ho fatto
valutare la mia bellissima idea con una
bellissima presentazione più bella di
questa un milione e mezzo ai primi tra i
dipendenti di cui vi parlavo prima ho
regalato ognuno l'uno per cento è come
se gli avessi dato 15 mila euro in tasca
sì è vero e carta vorrei vedere qualcuno
che va in banca e metà garanzie le quote
in una startup probabilmente direttore
chiamerebbe un trattamento sanitario
obbligatorio ma cercate di seguire il
ragionamento il secondo anno la società
ha iniziato a fare un pochino di
fatturato altri investitori arrivano e
la valutano solo il doppio di solito
invece il valore crescere 300 per cento
ogni anno
quindi l'uno per cento che per avevo
regalato viene un po diluito diventa 0
75 ma di 4 milioni quindi adesso i suoi
15mila sono diventati 30 ok in un anno
al terzo anno si raccolgono ancora soldi
la quota viene diluita
ma la valutazione aumenta e adesso vale
56.250 il 375 per cento valore iniziale
al quarto anno la stessa cosa al quinto
anno la società però inizia a fare utili
e quindi non c'è più bisogno di avere
nuovi investitori e quindi la
valutazione rimane uguale a quella
dell'anno prima
al sesto anno la società viene venduta
per 50 milioni
la vostra quota
provvidamente 210.000 938 euro andiamo a
vedere quindi questi valori vicino alla
retribuzione
il primo anno come dicevamo prendi 1700
ma ti ho regalato un 1 per cento di un
milione e mezzo che come se ti avessi
regalato 1.250 euro in più al mese
ok il secondo anno le sue quote valgono
il doppio
ma ti ho già dato i 15.000 di prima
quindi sono altri 15.000 diviso 12 altri
1200 50 al terzo anno come dicevo le
quote valgono 56 mila e 250 ma che ho
già riconosciuto 15 più 15 e quindi sono
26 mila e 250 diviso 12 ovvero 2.188
euro al mese
al quarto anno le quote valgono 100
26.563 ma ti ho già riconosciuto 15 15
26 250 quindi per quest'anno ahimè devi
solo dividersi 70.000 313 per 12 che
vede fuori 5.858 euro al mese
al quinto anno ci hai spiegato non ha
nessun incremento di valutazione alla
società quindi ti prendi solo lo
stipendio al sesto anno
ovviamente se si vive della società sei
stato tra i primi entrare e la società
viene venduta a 50 milioni come dicevo
la tua quota val improvvisamente 200
10.938 euro che tolto tutte le
distribuzioni precedenti
è come se avessi preso 7031 euro in più
al mese vi ho convinto
andiamo a vedere i totali e confrontate
il totale annuale del primo anno nel b
corp che se non ricordo male e 24mila e
nelle startup invece diventa 35.400 al
sesto anno nella b corp hai preso un
netto di 30 mila nella startup 116.000
vi ho convinto vero che nel gruppetto in
fondo ne è rimasto solo uno ok allora va
bene adesso vi spiego il perché bisogna
andare in una start up non si va in una
startup sfuggire alla ruota del criceto
che c'è nelle grandi aziende non si va
in una stata perché si guadagna di più
si va perché c'è il ping pong e mi
sembra un ottimo motivo no sbaglio c'è
anche il beer storm in questa vera
spirito è l'aperitivo che facciamo al
venerdì alle 18 offerto dalla società a
tutti i dipendenti e pagato ovviamente
con i soldi degli investitori in cui si
sparano cavolate su quello che
bisognerebbe fare se fossimo cinque
volte il numero di dipendenti attuali no
non ti ho convinto vabbè allora dài mio
gioco
ultima carta e lamento sul personale vi
racconto la mia storia era il 2014
stavo a londra avevo una società che
gestiva un sito web italiano prezzi
pazzi punto com e leggevo un blog online
tech crunch e scopro che questa società
americana in st carter che aveva appena
raccolto 50 milioni di dollari che fa
non è una cifra grossissima in silicon
valley sono due noccioline questi
facevano una cosa semplice avevano una
rete di fattorini che andava a prendere
la spesa in vari supermercati in tela
consegnava a casa in giornata e quando
ho letto questa cosa ho pensato che
fosse perfetta per il mercato italiano
così sono tornato in italia mi sono
messo a scrivere ai codici del sito web
e mi sono scaricato tutte le immagini
dei prodotti da uscito competitor
ok il mio primo sito si chiamava
supermarcato web puntonet era orribile
sembrava google del giorno uno solo
testo le uniche immagini era quello
erano quelle che avevo rubato dagli
altri siti
ma c'è una regola nel nostro settore nel
mondo delle startup che dice dan is
better than perfect e questa regola è la
più importante
ho quindi attivata una piccola campagna
su facebook e quattro ore dopo è
arrivato il primo cliente ed ero
contentissimo per questa cosa c'era solo
una cosa strana l'ordine era una
bottiglia di campari è un pacco di
cracker
ma sapete chi fa le cose nelle startup
gli start up così ho preso la mia
vespetta e sono andato al supermercato
ho preso in campari e paco di cracker e
sono andato a consegnarlo e sorpresa e
cliente non era un nerd come me non
signore anziano con ridotta mobilità e
mi aveva trovato pensate tramite la mia
pubblicità su facebook per me era
incredibile sapete cosa è successo il
giorno dopo
niente di nuovo ho fatto ancora la spesa
per altre persone sempre quella mia
rispetta e ogni giorno sembrava sempre
di più un impiccione perché non ti
aspetti diciamo il rider che viene a
casa e ti chiede come ti sei trovato
quella user experience dell'interfaccia
eccetera
fino a 20 giorni dopo quando facevo 7
spese al giorno e non avevo neppure il
tempo per fermarmi ho dovuto quindi
creare tutto dal servizio clienti a una
rete di shopper che andasse a fare la
spesa i primi 200 shopper li ho
incontrati 11 stretto a tutti la mano ho
assunto i programmatori loro hanno
assunto altre persone insomma abbiamo
fatto l'impresa
ora siamo più di 220 dipendenti tra
verona e milano la cecoslovacchia la
polonia e la francia e lo scorso anno
abbiamo fatto più di 100 milioni di euro
in sei anni crescendo del 400 per cento
ogni anno
questa è la differenza tra andare a
lavorare per qualcuno e fare start up
cosa dovrebbe insegnarvi questa
storiella la cosa più importante non si
smette mai di imparare io non avevo mai
fatto il rider l'ho imparato e non avevo
mai assunto così tante persone
il tuo lavoro è importante tu sei
importante in un'impresa che inizia da
zero soprattutto quando si ha in pochi
non ti annoi non troverai mai la scusa
per la pausa caffè ogni giorno si è
spinto a fare qualcosa di diverso
ingegnerizzando e passarlo ai nuovi
assunti lavori con i migliori quelli che
pensano fuori dal coro che si prendono
dei rischi che vogliono arrivare al
successo e l'ambiente ragazzi è
fantastico è come andare a scuola a
nessuno di fregargli come se hai vestito
ma solo quanto sei bravo a ping pong
grazie